[Applause]
[Music]
looking to manage access to your
organization's google cloud resources
with ease
give me one minute and i'll show you how
with cloud identity and access
management
cloud identity and access management
enables you to grant access to cloud
resources
at fine grained levels and gives you
visibility and tools for centrally
managing your cloud resources
access can be granted to resources based
on attributes like resource type
so that users get access only to what
they need to get the job done
iam provides a unified view into
security policy across your entire
organization
with built-in auditing to ease your
compliance processes
use cloud iam with resource manager to
easily modify your access policies for
your organization
folders and projects built-in policy
intelligence
machine learning and automation tools
help you reduce your risk
for example iam recommender
automatically detects overly permissive
access
and helps you right size cloud iam
resource manager and the tools and
policy intelligence
are available in the cloud console
gcloud command line tool
and programmatically through rest apis
so next time you're looking to smartly
and efficiently manage secure access to
your cloud deployment
take a minute to look at cloud iam to
learn
more check out cloud.google.com iam